there are many surprising stories on the
stage of world history the invention of
the automobile is one and so our play
begins in the 1670s Ferdinand verbiage
was a flemish missionary and scientist
he was sent to visit the court of the
kang zi emperor in China the Emperor's
court was a dangerous place
when verbiage arrived he was held
prisoner almost chopped to bits but
instead was forced to compete in a
series of math and astronomy contests
you know like you do ultimately ver bein
so impressed the Emperor he banished the
current astronomer and gave verbiage ah
over the years they became friends verby
is tutored the emperor in geometry
philosophy and music around 1670 to
verby is designed as a toy for his
friend the Emperor a steam propelled
trolley it was an automobile in the
truest sense no one really knows if it
got built the drawings that verbiage did
are all that remains nonetheless those
designs are most likely the earliest
self moving machine ever conceived many
automobiles would follow over the years
but few were conceived as a gift to a
merciful emperor / BFF
[Music]